well another season of American Horror
Story has ended and this one we'll have
you saying I'm looking for something
that says
dad likes leather something that says
leather daddy season 11 titled New York
will have fans of the show divided with
the bulk of its horror manifesting not
in a monster slasher or Supernatural
element but the AIDS epidemic that's not
to say the season is without its
trademark Killers we'll definitely get
into that but those take a back seat as
the characters face a far more vicious
and unrelenting foe so put on your
leather outfits let's take a look at
what New York has to offer the year is
1981 I'm not even born yet and New York
is under attack bodies of dead men have
been springing up around the city their
corpses chopped into various pieces and
no one seems to be doing anything about
it NYPD officer Patrick Reed has noticed
a pattern all these men are gay but when
He suggests the department look into it
he's dismissed the force can't be
spending all its time and money on men
who are runaways getting caught up in
drugs and illegal activities so
Patrick's boyfriend and I should mention
Patrick's still in the closet a man by
the name of Gino Borelli decides to take
matters into his own hands he runs a gay
paper called the native and wants to
bring attention to this killer who's
targeting their Community what we'll
find out is that there are actually two
killers one will come to know as the Mai
Thai killer aptly named since he would
buy his victims my ties and the other
big daddy at the end of episode 1 Gino's
investigation leads him to a bar where
he's drugged by the mai tai killer but
when the killer finds out Gino was in
the military he spares his life he won't
kill a fellow brother in arms it isn't
until episode 7 that we find out what
the Killer's true motivations are why is
he targeting gay men and chopping them
into pieces the identity of the killers
discovered when it turns out one of
Geno's sources a gay Hitman by the name
of Henry used to employ him to dispose
of bodies when he worked for the mob the
man goes by Mr Whiteley a male nurse
ex-vietnam vet with a penchant for my
ties when Gino and Patrick go to
investigate they're captured by him and
are shocked to discovered the Sentinel a
Frankenstein type monster sewn together
by different parts of gay men he killed
to create a quote Beacon of Hope for the
gay community like Gino and Patrick the
Mai Thai killer believes the plight of
the gay community falls on deaf ears no
one cares about them so in order to make
people care he must show the world their
suffering by killing over and over again
and constructing this gruesome creature
he wants to show the world how they've
been treated The Sentinel is our
Salvation he will save us he will show
the world our suffering and will redeem
us this is how the Mai Thai killer
justifies his murders he believes them
to be necessary sacrifices in the
greater fight for justice but his plans
are foiled when Patrick is saved by Gino
and Henry you see the Mai Thai killer
had no use for Gino and Henry and had
them locked in another room Patrick
whoever was wanted for his quote Brave
heart you see the Sentinels composed of
only the very best parts of his victims
beautiful parts for the outside and
Noble parts for the inside Patrick's
heart will be the last part needed to
create the mai tai Killer's Masterpiece
but on getting free Patrick Ames is
gonna the killer where we can see the
host of victims he killed behind him the
Killer is shot ending his Rampage at the
end of the episode Gina writes that
within the gate community lies a monster
one built up by society's expectations
on who and what they are if you believe
the gay community to be criminals
deviants and monsters that's what you'll
become so He suggests to throw away what
Society thinks and be proud of who you
are and only then can you become your
own Sentinel with the Mai Thai Killer
dead you'd think the killings would stop
this is American Horror Story and there
are three more episodes to go throughout
the season many of our characters have
been stalked by this Beast of a man
known as Big Daddy his first appearance
is in episode 1 when a character by the
name of Adam finds him in Central Park
but as the season progresses and more
and more care characters have run-ins
with him some more deadly than others
but big daddy isn't real at least the
physical manifestation of him he's
rather a metaphor for the AIDS epidemic
which was first officially reported in
the United States in 1981 the same year
the show is set in episode 1 we meet Dr
Hannah Wells who's investigating an
unknown virus affecting deer on Fire
Island her suggestion is to kill all the
deer so the virus doesn't have the time
to LEAP to humans Fire Island also
happens to be a favorite spot for the
gay community to party the deer
therefore become a metaphor for the
lives slaughtered by HIV AIDS Dr Wells
also meets with a woman claiming to know
the origins of the virus this is Fran
she worked as a lab assistant on Plum
Island where she claims doctors mixed
animal diseases with human ones to
engineer a virus that could Target
specific people ticks then would become
this delivery mechanism and since AIDS
was first reported rumors circulated
that the virus was created by the CIA to
wipe out [ __ ] sexuals and African
Americans back on nearby Fire Island
Theo Graves is killed by Big Daddy as
his Fallen Brothers to the disease and
meet him in death in fact almost every
character who doesn't die to the Mai
Thai killer dies to Big Daddy Dr Hannah
Wells the person who first tried to
raise alarm over this new virus
contracts it while using her best friend
Adam Seaman to conceive using a turkey
baster no less don't ask me how that
works it's implied Adam contracted it
while being visited by Big Daddy in
Central Park but there are two
characters who are seen by ghosts of
ex-lovers while dying to the virus the
first is Sam played by Zachary Quinto
he's a high-end art collector in love
with Theo Graves a star photographer
whose work brings out the beauty in the
ugly Sam is haunted by Theo who shows
him dying alone in the hospital all his
money and wealth mean nothing now Sam is
obsessed with giving people pain and
this stems from his childhood as a child
he was abused by his father and as a
young man even though he worked hard
harder and faster than any of his
colleagues he was overlooked for
promotions because he was gay thus he
spent his life hoarding art and money to
stick it to the Wall Street Boys in his
final moments Sam is confronted by Big
Daddy but when he takes off Big Daddy's
Mass he turns into a beautiful man
remember Theo's artwork centered around
finding the beauty in the ugly and
that's what Sam is finally doing here
he's turning something ugly and making
it beautiful before he dies the second
person to be visited by a ghost is
Patrick his ex-wife Barbara who he
unknowingly gave the virus to acts as a
sort of Ghost of Christmas Past showing
him how the trauma of his life made him
who he was and only by confronting it
can he truly move on Patrick had to hide
who he was at work and even turns
against his gay partner his father
despised him for being a wussy who
couldn't fire a gun and this pain Barber
says it broke into pieces just like the
mai tai Killer cut up his victims into
pieces Gino is the only one there for
Patrick in his final days Patrick's IV
hasn't been changed he hasn't gotten any
food more evidence to show that these
patients were seen as Pariah even in his
death Patrick's family snubbed Geno and
closed the casket even though he and
Patrick wanted it to be open so that the
world could see what he died from Adam
Carpenter who had been helping Geno
expose this killer among the community
continues the investigation as Gino's
illness worsens at every corner Adam
learns the hard truth that no one seems
to care the doctor at the morgue refuses
to believe any of these deaths are
related and Pizzazz the bathhouse owner
says she's contacted Public Health about
her patrons becoming sick but no one has
come we see Geno by AZT the first drug
to treat HIV infection which has some
serious adverse effects Big Daddy
frequently visits him a reminder of the
illness that will slowly consume him
much of the episode is a visual
representation of the devastation this
virus has caused we see dozens of men
fall into their own Graves Gino drinks
green liquid a metaphor for the
radioactive therapy he and so many went
through from 1987 to 1991 we see how the
virus affects Geno and those around him
he'll succumb to the virus making sure
to have an open casket leaving Adam one
of the only few characters alive at the
end of the season but now I want to hear
what you thought has the show tread too
far from its roots or has it
successfully transcended into something
else let me know what you think in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember Daddy loves you
very much
foreign